hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear and it's still march so
we're still doing
monster march that's the theme for this
month now interestingly the movie that
i'm talking about today is one that for
whatever reason i had actually never
heard of
and it got recommended to me i think it
was when we were doing uh one of our
side tracks live streams like on friday
night and i mentioned that i was doing
monster themed movies uh for my march
reviews and so i was kind of looking for
some suggestions like i had some lined
up but i was kind of like well some of
these you know maybe i'll do them maybe
i won't but if other people want to see
other ones or have recommendations for
stuff that i hadn't uh thought of then i
wanted to hear what they were
so this was one of the movies that was
recommended and all uh all that was
recommended was oh there's this movie
because i said oh i was thinking about
maybe doing like throwing a bigfoot
movie in there you know maybe exists or
willow creek or something like that and
somebody said oh you should do a movie
called abominable
that's kind of like a bigfoot movie and
i think they mistakenly said it came out
in 2001 it actually came out in 2006 but
whatever close enough uh but the thing
they said that really sparked my
interest was jeffrey combs is in it and
i was just like jeffrey combs say no
more i'm sold um i don't care i love
jeffrey combs and i will watch pretty
much anything that he's in so it's crazy
i don't know how this movie slipped
under my radar maybe because i think it
debuted as a sci-fi original i might be
mistaken about that
but the amount of like horror cameos in
this and
the people that worked on it like behind
the scenes that have like a lot of
connections with uh not just horror
movies but just like kind of big hor big
movies in general um so i'm actually
kind of surprised that this didn't get
like more
i don't know like more attention um you
know it's not the best movie ever but it
was actually pretty entertaining
and i gotta say for
uh the director's first movie and for as
low budget as this movie presumably was
uh the monster design and the gore
effects were pretty damn awesome uh you
know so and especially because it was
all practical
now you are not gonna believe like how
many now some of these some of the
people that i'm saying are in this movie
um are it amounts to like extended
cameos but the short screen time that
some of them have um they absolutely
make the best of it so one of those
being jeffrey combs he's in like two or
three scenes and he's great he kind of
plays this
sort of backwoods um guy who works at a
gas station convenience store
and he's got like these sort of coke
bodily glasses and he has like his
oxygen tank with his you know tube under
his nose and stuff like that and he's
actually one of the people that believes
in sasquatch uh and everyone just thinks
he's a nut so like i said he's only in
like two scenes but he totally steals it
i mean like i said how can you not love
jeffrey combs he's awesome uh so so yeah
so he's great in it also you have a
cameo by the awesome lance henriksen uh
who is always fantastic he's he's only
in one scene but uh he really does make
an impression uh he's basically it's him
and jeffrey combs and one other
character and they're sort of like these
hunters and they're sitting around a
fire and lance henriksen talks about the
darwin awards and he tells this really
disgusting story involving a constipated
rhino um you know what i mean so if
you've seen it it kind of made me gag a
little bit like they don't show anything
but just him telling it i was like oh
that's one of the grossest [ __ ]
things i've ever heard uh you also have
a cameo from d wallace stone uh she's
actually in the
uh prologue
and she doesn't uh turn up again after
that but she's uh again great and uh
also paul gleason in this who i feel
like he always played villains like in
80s movies and [ __ ] like that like you
know everybody will remember him as the
uptight principal from the breakfast
club but he was in millions of other
things too always kind of playing that
same kind of role so those are sort of
your
big name big ticket
uh cameos in this and they really do uh
lend something awesome to the film now
the movie was written and directed by
ryan schifrin
now
he doesn't have a lot of film credits to
his name this was actually his first
feature film i think he's done some
shorts he did actually do a segment in
uh tales of halloween an anthology movie
from 2015 i think it was i think
actually we reviewed it either last
halloween of the halloween before uh
that's actually a really good halloween
um
anthology movie if you're looking for
one you haven't seen it and i think it's
free on 2b if you want to watch it so he
did one of the segments in that
now interestingly he uh is the son
of uh lalo shifrin who if you know
anything about movies i think we even
talked about him a little bit when we
talked about the steve mcqueen movie
bullet because he actually the score for
that uh he's also the guy that composed
the theme from mission impossible he did
cool him luke enter the dragon and evil
[ __ ] the dirty harry movies like he's
done a [ __ ] ton of film scores and
indeed i'm supposing as a favor to his
son he does he does the score for this
little bigfoot movie as well which i
don't know i just thought that was
pretty awesome
interestingly too there's a kind of a
main character in this film
played by
christian tinsley uh he plays kind of a
nurse guy named otis
and uh he's a real he's a real piece of
work he's a real [ __ ] uh i actually
quite enjoyed him in this movie even
though i'm not i'll get into it a little
bit but i'm not really entirely sure
like what his deal is like why he was so
much of a dick but whatever
uh so this is actually his first acting
role and i didn't know this
but christian tinsley who i believe also
did most of the special effects work on
this movie
also won an oscar in 2004 for doing the
special effects of passion for passion
of the christ of all things uh and he
also does like his uh special effects
company also does effects uh for
american horror story westworld the you
know the series santa clarita diet so as
i said everybody pretty much everybody
involved in this is kind of like a big
deal like in the horror thing so it's
surprising that i didn't hear of it also
this movie has uh kind of a little small
role for uh tiffany sheppas who i had
seen her before she looked very familiar
she actually got her start in tromeo and
juliet and if you go to her wikipedia
page she has been
in five bajillion like b grade like
horror movies uh so she's kind of like
the bee scream queen like going at the
moment she does get naked in this so i
guess that's kind of a thing i haven't i
don't know i've probably seen her in
something else because i think i had
seen a couple of other movies that she
was in
but i was watching uh bloodbath and
beyond and they did a breakdown of this
and the one guy that was on there was
like super into her and it was kind of
like oh hey we get to see her naked so
that's always like a big plus and she
gets pulled through a window and snapped
in half so there is that as well now the
main character of this though uh is
played by matt mccoy who
is was very familiar to me although i
couldn't immediately place him and then
when i went and looked at his backstory
i'm recognizing him from the hand that
rocks the cradle uh he played the dad in
that uh and apparently he was also on
seinfeld although i didn't recognize him
from that because i haven't seen many
episodes of that but probably people
most people recognize him from that
so he's in this as sort of like the main
character the strange thing about this
movie it's kind of strange but like kind
of awesome kind of
uh kind of audacious i want to say this
is essentially a bigfoot movie a
sasquatch movie killer sasquatch
but and i never thought that i would say
these two things together but it's also
kind of an homage to alfred hitchcock's
rear window
and i know i know what you're thinking
and i thought that too i'm like watching
up like this is like rear window but
with a killer sasquatch and again that's
the sentence i never thought i would say
out loud i was like i wasn't really sure
it was gonna work but i'm like all right
all right i'm going along with you on
this journey that's fine
so uh so matt mccoy is our main
character
now he's uh a guy named preston rogers
and at the beginning of the movie he is
coming back to his cabin after
six months away you don't find out that
it's six months until later on so
apparently what happened uh him and his
wife had this cabin out here in the
mountains
and six months ago uh him and his wife
were climbing on quote-unquote suicide
rock and she fell to her death and he
also fell but was actually just uh made
into a paraplegic so now he's in a
wheelchair
so he comes back to the um to the cabin
with otis who is his you know care nurse
why is otis such a chode i'm not
entirely sure they don't really go into
why
he's acting this way like why and why
everybody um because really the only
setup for it because uh preston's just
kind of like look i really didn't want
to come back to this cabin it's just
it's not you know i haven't had enough
time to process my wife's death you know
i'm not ready for this and that you know
otis just kind of blows it off well the
doctor said that you should it'll be
good for you so tough [ __ ] you know what
i mean he's like basically kind of
treating him like crap the whole time
because he's sort of like over his thing
and like i said i thought that's kind of
the only criticism that i have of this
is that
i thought that there was going to be
some other like motivation for why otis
was
acting like that much of an [ __ ] like
toward him like i thought he had some
kind of like ulterior motive or
something which he doesn't really but i
don't know it's it it's not that big a
deal i'm just like otis is just a dick
and that's just kind of what his
personality is uh so there's that
so they come back to uh to this thing
to the cabin and um you know and
preston's having a hard time because he
hasn't been there in a long time
obviously since the tragedy and
everything's just the same you know
everything's covered with dust and he's
kind of having a little bit of a you
know a little bit of emotional uh
breakdown or whatever
and then it turns out that
his uh nurse has to go because i guess
like uh there's a whole thing where
preston is like allergic to milk and he
has to have everything with soy and so
otis like forgot to get soy milk so he
has to go back to the back to town and
get it so he's gonna be gone for a while
so uh you know preston's left on his own
now uh it so happens too that there's
another cabin that's like right across
the way
and into this cabin we have some more
cannon fodder for the killer sasquatch
in the form of five young women who have
come there for kind of like a
bachelorette weekend type situation
these five women are not really all that
developed like as characters because as
i said this almost comes across like a
killer sasquatch version of rear window
in the sense that you're almost always
seeing everything from preston's point
of view because he can't move uh you
know he's well he's in his wheelchair
and he can't like get out of the house
so he's basically like watching uh the
woods because he hears or sees something
going on out there and he suspects that
there's something out there that took
one of the girls at some point and so
most of the movie is him trying to like
warn them that there's something outside
and like they need to figure out what
the hell is going on so you don't really
get a lot of um you know character
development as far as the young women
are i didn't really remember i
remembered one of them's name was karen
because you know obviously you're gonna
remember and she had like a funny last
name too like heard burger or turd
burton it was a turd burger why didn't i
say that
i heard burger i think it was but i
can't and one and then the later girl
the final girl that actually does
survive her name's amanda but i i didn't
even actually know that until later on
like after everybody else was dead so
but i didn't remember any of the other
three uh names because like i said
essentially they're just there to get
killed by this uh by this monster
so uh so as i mentioned pretty much the
whole entire movie
is from preston's point of view there
comes a thing where finally
otis who spent like 40 million years at
the store and i guess he came back and
was like oh it took me a long time to
find soy milk so you're presuming that
he had to like drive farther away to get
it or whatever but he was gone for a
really long time and it was like dark
when it came back and then um preston
during this time has actually seen he
hasn't actually seen the sasquatch
but he's seen something big like farting
around in the woods there's like a whole
thing where one of the um the power
lines and the phone line thing is like
uh knocked down
and he sees one of the girls from next
door
has gone out to talk on her cell phone
because the reception's not that great
and there's kind of like a rustling and
then she's disappeared and he can see
that her phone is just like laying there
so he's worried that she got you know
snatched into the woods by something or
someone and so he's trying to
warn the girls like hey go out there and
see where your friend is you know i
think something bad happened and because
he's just sitting there at the window
because he can't get out of the house
and because when otis returns he just
thinks that
that preston is having like a nervous
breakdown because he's back in the cabin
where his wife died and you know and
he's not really handling it all that
well so otis is just being a dick and
being like look there's nothing out
there like what the [ __ ] are you doing
and he basically just thinks that
preston is watching the girls like being
a peeping tom because he keeps like
looking over there like with his uh with
his binoculars and he's like no i'm just
like you know and then obviously they
all have like their [ __ ] windows open
and they're all like showering and stuff
like that so so like i said there is
some of that in there too but he's like
no i'm serious he's like i'm just trying
to warn them because there's something
going on in the woods so he tries to
like uh contact the police like because
he has like a the power goes out and the
phones go out at some point and he
doesn't have a cell phone because like i
said this is 2006 and it's funny because
i forgot
i mean to me 2006 doesn't seem that long
ago but now that i'm thinking about i'm
like oh yeah that was a [ __ ] long
time ago so like all the um cell phones
and like all the email like technology
and everything like that looks so
[ __ ] ancient and it's just like
hilarious to me i was like oh my god i
forgot how long ago 2006 was so yeah so
there's like this big thing where he has
a satellite uplink and he's trying to
like email the police they think that
he's just playing a prank
you know ooh the flatwoods monster which
actually like is a real i think the
flatwoods thing well that was an alien
though wasn't it but they're kind of
like homaging like uh like that the
because they call it like the flatwoods
monster like there's an urban legend
about it or whatever and uh so there's
that uh kind of whole thing going on too
so he's so basically the whole thing
like i said much like rear window
is him insisting that something bad is
going on out there and otis and them
like not really believing him and him
having a hard time communicating his
worries to the police or to the girls uh
to try to save them so that's pretty
much how the movie goes on like i said
there's a little diversion uh after
karen gets taken with the hunters uh you
know with uh jeffrey combs and lance
henriksen and like one other guy who was
d wallace stone's husband from the
beginning of the movie who actually they
didn't get killed but they saw what they
thought was uh the sasquatch that killed
like their horse and their dog and stuff
and uh off screen it doesn't kill the
you know you see the dead horse it's
like [ __ ] up but the dog gets killed
off screen so you don't have to worry
too much about that you know how i'm
about animal deaths in movies but uh so
there was that so the three of them are
like at a thing and they all get
they all get killed as well uh you know
but other than that it's pretty much
stays with preston's character and him
trying to like warn the girls and the
girls kind of getting picked off one by
one as the sasquatch attacks when
sasquatches attack there's a new show on
the history channel i'm sure
but uh yeah what did i like about this
movie i loved loved the monster design
the sasquatch in this
it's a guy in a suit
but
i mean i will take that over cgi any
[ __ ] day of the week because i do
kind of feel like a lot of sasquatch
bigfoot type movie especially like newer
ones nowadays and especially ones that
were on sci-fi channel uh they're all
gonna use like cg monsters and it's just
not gonna look all that good
uh this monster looks pretty [ __ ]
cool i have to say uh the actor that
played him like the stunt man or actor
that uh played him
was apparently very tall like six foot
five and the suit itself made him much
taller like eight feet tall so he looks
very big and very intimidating he's very
wide they did a great [ __ ] uh
animatronic face on him like he has
these crazy like glowing eyes that kind
of go like that and his teeth like look
fantastic i love the mouth that they did
on it it looks like recognizably a
sasquatch but it looks different than
any other sasquatch you've seen so it
does kind of look like you know like a
big ape but they did their own thing to
make it look more monstery and i think
they did a really good job of it i
really really like the monster design
the face and everything like that so
great uh also
the gore in this fantastic i mean
i can't decide which one is my favorite
okay so there's these two great scenes
as i mentioned um
tiffany shepas who is in this and she
does like a nude scene because one of
the other girls they get in a fight and
she throws a margarita on her it's a
whole thing and so she has to go
immediately and like take all her
clothes off and get in the shower as you
do
and you know what i mean i guess it's in
her contract i guess it's like you're
gonna be in the movie you have to get
your kid off at some point so she does
uh you know she's game for it and uh so
she's in there and then the basically
the sasquatch like like breaks the
bathroom window and like reaches through
there and grabs her and pulls her out
through the window so she like snaps in
half like backwards and it looks really
good um you don't see a lot of blood but
just like thinking about it you're just
kind of like oh man that's [ __ ] up i
like the sound effect and everything i
can't decide if that was my favorite
kill or when otis gets killed uh because
otis who actually because he's being
such uh such a dick and you know he's
not really believing preston and he's
kind of like getting in the way of his
[ __ ] and everything and he's actually
gonna give preston a sedative like to
get him to shut up but preston kind of
gets the drop on him and gives the otis
the sedative instead so he's asleep for
most of the movie like for most of the
crazy [ __ ] going on but when he actually
wakes up toward the end and he does
actually try to help and contribute like
he does try to
uh to save one of the girls from the
sasquatch and then the sasquatch turns
around
and legit bites the whole entire
front of his face off and it looks so
good it's just so good i really really
liked the gore effects in this they look
fantastic and like i said that's what
happens when you
have all these connections with like all
these people in the horror because like
i said christian tinsley is the guy that
played otis he's also like the special
effects guy and i gotta say he did like
a great great job on this only criticism
is that
a lot of the deaths and you know i'm not
gonna [ __ ] on too hard because it's low
budget you know what are you gonna do
and the few kills that you do see
look terrific but there's a lot of kills
in it that kind of happen off screen and
like i said i can see why they did that
because of budgetary constraints you
can't make you can't you know i think
eight people end up getting how many
people get and get killed in this it's
quite it's a lot um you know pretty much
all the girls get killed the three
hundreds get killed otis gets killed uh
so you know every pretty much everybody
gets killed
and uh but you only see i think three of
them like up close and personal like
most of the other ones
happen like you see karen
she's like in i guess the sasquatch has
like dragged her to a cave and she's
still alive but like you see her and
like her innards are kind of hanging out
which is that kind of looks kind of cool
but she don't actually see her
get killed like she just gets dragged
off and so like a lot of the victims do
just kind of get dragged off by a
sasquatch and then get killed off screen
uh including jeffrey combs and all of
them which like i said i'm i don't
really want to criticize too hard
because as i said the the kills that you
do see uh look really really good and i
actually i'm kind of glad that they made
the decision look if you don't have the
money to show eight people or whatever
getting killed and you can't do
super good quality on all of them then
just like pick out a few and make them
like really really good and really
really memorable and that's what they
did um only other thing uh that i can i
think maybe this was
this was maybe the director like i said
trying to homage uh you know a hitchcock
film trying to homage rear window a lot
of close-ups in this um
which to me it was i don't know it was
just it's not usually something i notice
in movies like because you know they
they do have the whole patterns like
would you close up long shot blah blah
but i kind of felt like the close-ups
there was a lot of them and they were
like just a little too close and i can't
it's been a while since i've seen rare
window but i thought maybe he was trying
to homage that a little bit with like
making this sort of so so i'm gonna say
that a lot of this movie is like
close-ups of
preston's face you know what i mean like
reacting to things and looking through
windows and it's just like a little bit
too close to be comfortable but it looks
like i mean it was obviously done
deliberately so it was a little strange
in that i noticed it because i was like
oh my god like so many so many close-ups
and they're like right and there was
like one scene where
otis character
is like drinking a glass of milk with
vodka in it and they do like kind of an
extreme close-up like on his face and
like do this sort of like asmr like of
him like drinking it and it's really
gross like the sound and i'm like i'm
not really sure why that why that was in
there but um but yeah so there was that
so that was a little bit
odd to me like it was an odd choice but
they it was obviously done deliberately
for some purpose i'm not entirely sure
what the purpose was but whatever you do
you um you know they i'm sure it was he
had some kind of reason for doing it i
just couldn't like figure out what it
was but yeah so
uh all in all this was actually a pretty
damn fun
movie it was a little like
weirder than i was expecting i guess
just because but i mean for a sci-fi
original movie if that's what it was i
think that i i mean i don't think it
says on the wikipedia page but from what
i could determine uh i think i don't
know if it was sci-fi original if it
just like premiered on the sci-fi
channel like back in 2006 and uh as most
people know those sci-fi original movies
are usually
not really all that great um you know a
lot of them will go kind of like over
the top and just make like a comedy like
sharknado this movie
had some comedic stuff in it um you know
in the sense of like jeffrey combs
character being kind of funny um and you
know some of the others like lance
henriksen's thing being kind of funny
but
not over the top funny i don't think i
would necessarily call this a comedy
most of it's played pretty straight
and particularly toward the end
where
you're getting into like the final
confrontation with preston and the and
the final girl from next door amanda and
they're trying to like save their asses
uh you know from the killer sasquatch
and actually there's there's a couple
scenes in there that are actually quite
heartfelt uh where pr where preston is
like talking about uh telling her about
his dead wife and stuff like that and i
was like wow that was that was actually
kind of nice like a little character
moment and stuff like that which i don't
think they would usually bother to put
in a sci-fi movie or if they did it
would be like super cheesy and it's
really not cheesy in this um it really
is preston's character is very much
played straight and because he's
grieving um he doesn't really crack a
lot of jokes or anything like that there
are comedic moments in it like i said
otis is kind of funny some of the other
characters kind of funny but it's not
like comedic they generally take it
fairly seriously but
it still like has that sense of fun to
it as well so i think it was like a good
balance and as i said i love the
creature design i think the sasquatch in
this looks so so good so much better
than cgi i mean you know what i mean i
just love the real distinctive look of
it i love his teeth they look fantastic
and a lot of the gore kills what you do
get in this are really really good
especially otis getting his face bit off
i just loved that
i just wanted to watch it
i don't know it was just like really
funny to me but yeah so uh so if you've
seen this movie uh let me know what you
think about it in the comments uh if
you'd like to watch it it's actually on
2b at the moment for free might be on
some other streaming services as well
but yeah this is totally worth watching
especially if like sasquatch movies you
like kind of like fun monster movies
that are real gory uh has some nudity in
it too if you're into that and as i said
it's kind of like a spot the horror
legend cameo kind of thing going on in
there too so i thought that was pretty
cool but it did it in a way that wasn't
like hey look who we got in the movie
you know what i mean it wasn't like
self-referential or too
it wasn't like too aware of itself i
guess they were just kind of like in
there so i thought it was like really
well done in that regard so yeah this
was actually a lot of fun and i would
like to uh give a shout out to
uh whoever it was and i can't remember
who it was because it was just
it was in the uh chat on the live stream
and i was probably a little bit
inebriated at the time i remember i was
i was sober enough to write down the
name of the movie but
but i wasn't safe enough to remember who
it was that suggested it but thank you
for suggesting it because it actually uh
was a lot of fun and i had a good time
watching it so uh yeah that'll do it for
this flickers of fear uh continuing on
with monster march and i will see you
guys on the next one bye